افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بنقل ثلاثه
عسكريين الى مستشفى سوروكا في بئر السبع
بعد اصابتهم بجروح خطيره في معارك بقطاع
غزه وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن اصابه 12
عسكريا في معارك قطاع غزه خلال الساعات
ال4 الماضيه وحسب ارقام الجيش الاسرائيلي
فان
28 ضابطا وجنديا اصيبوا منذ بدء الحرب
وبذلك ير فع عدد جرحى الجيش الاسرائيلي
منذ بدء الهجوم البري الى
1314 وفقا للجيش
الاسرائيلي معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله
الجزيره فاطمه خميسي فاطمه ضعنا في هذه
الاحصائيات المعلنه مع نقل المزيد من جرحى
جيش الاحتلال الى المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه نعم سلمى حتى هذه اللحظه
نتحدث عن نقل ثلاثه عسكريين اسرائيليين
وصفت جراحهم بالخطه الى مشفى سوروكا في
بئر السبع القريب من قطاع غزه هذا الامر
يضاف كما ذكرت الى اصابه 12 جنديا ايضا
بجروح متفاوته خلال المعارك الدائره في
الساعات ال4 الماضيه ايضا كان هنالك
تقارير تتحدث عن ان مجمل الاصابات في
الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدء هذه الحرب نتحدث
عن نحو 20% من هذه الاصابات كانت نتائج
حوادث عمل عمليات نتحدث عن مثلا حوادث دهس
اطلاق واصابات عبر نيران صديقه وايضا
حوادث بالتفجيرات التي تحصل وكان هنالك
الحدث الابرز هو قيام الجيش الاسرائيلي
بقتل عدد من الاسرى نتحدث ثلاثه اسرى قام
قتلهم بعد تشخيص خاطئ ايضا هنالك اصابات
في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي نتيجه التشخيص
الخاطئ ونتيجه العمليات المركبه في قطاع
غزه على المستوى الميداني حتى هذه اللحظه
نسمع اصوات انفجارات جدا عنيفه في منطقه
شمال قطاع غزه ومنطقه الوسط وفي بيان
الجيش الاسرائيلي الاخير قال بان سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي قام باحباط عمليه لزرع
عبوات ناسفه تحديدا في منطقه غرب خان يونس
وايضا استهدف خلايا مسلحه يقول بانها
تابعه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه المقاومه في منطقه بيت لاهيه
عبر رصد معلومات استخباراتيه وقصفه من
الجو طبعا كنا قد شاهدنا ايضا اعمده
الدخان التي تتصاعد من خلف في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا في منطقه وسط غلاف غزه والمعارك لا
تزال محتدمه ايضا هنالك اشتباكات بال
الرشاشات الثقيله ونسمع اطلاق ل الاعيره
الناريه بالاضافه الى تحليق مستمر لطائرات
الاستطلاع الاسرائيليه بشكل كثيف خاصه في
الساعات الاخيره طبعا هنالك تلويح ايضا من
قبل رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو بشن عمليه عسكريه بريه في منطقه
رفح ولكن الضغوط الدوليه والامريكيه تحول
دون ذلك وفق المعلومات التي نشرتها تقارير
اخباريه اسرائيليه على موقع واللا
الاسرائيلي وعلى ما يبدو ان ايضا انسحاب
الفرقه ال 36 التي تحتوي على اللواء
السادس والسابع من وحده جولاني وايضا
الوحده 188 التابعه ل
الهه من قطاع غزه ونقلها الى معسكرات
التدريب ثم سوف يتم وضعها في الجبه
الشماليه تشير الى صحه هذه الاقوال ولكن
بنيامين نتنياهو يعني يحاول التلويح في
هذا الامر للضغط على حركه حماس عبر
استمرار العمليات العسكريه والان ايضا
نسمع استمرار القصف العنيف شكرا لك من
غلاف غزه مراسلتنا فاطمه
خميسي